ça fait partie de du nom d'une des
banderilles que j'ai planté dans la
commission agriculture au parlement
européen sur la nécessité de adapter le
droit de la concurrence aux spécificités
du monde agricole soit de la concurrence
ayant été fait pour les produits
industriels et non pas pour les produits
agricoles mais ça n'est qu'une bande riz
je pense qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
chemin avant qu'on obtienne un résultat
pascal ton toi tu es à bruxelles au
travers du copain peut-être voilà nous
fait nous donner un témoignage de la
place que peut et que doit occuper la
france dans ce concert européen
merci angélique bonjour à tous d'abord
je suis très heureux d'être parmi vous
aujourd'hui
d'abord en tant que famille des
républicains puisque je suis maire de la
motte beuvron et conseil départemental
change de l'aviculture loir et cher pour
les républicains
donc c'est un plaisir d'être là ce matin
dans ma famille politique et puis d'y
être aussi en tant qu'agriculteur je
suis moi originaire du cantal d'un
élevage allaitant et j'ai monté une
diversification agrotouristique cheval
ce qui m'a amené en sologne par les
hasards de d'une prise de
responsabilités sur le centre national
de la fédération française d'équitation
en plein soleil
donc je suis arrivé
à prendre des responsabilités dans les
organisations professionnelles agricoles
françaises pour défendre cette activité
le cheval c'est une petite production
agricole d'abord parce qu'on leur
l'utilisent plus qu'on le mange dans
cette danse est dans cette activité et
on a on a eu sous nos responsabilités
gouvernementales différentes une
structuration de la filière qui a été
bénéfique
d'abord avec la décision qui a été prise
par le sénateur à l'époque ministre
délégué au budget alain lambert qui a
fiscalisés notre filière puisqu'on était
des statuts complètement disparates
je parle de la filière équitation et qui
a rejailli aussi sur l'ensemble de la
filière pêche qui avait les cours ce qui
était pour l'été fiscalisés au même au
même taux à l'époque à un taux de tva
réduit et les allègements qui était dûe
au monde agricole ce que nous n'avions
pas avant et on a connu sous la
présidence de nicolas sarkozy
tout à l'heure en tonnerre parler de
colbert mais nous colbert on le subit en
comment le sublime parce que on a eu une
influence et une présence de l'état très
fortes avec les haras nationaux qui nous
ont pas mal pas réalisés dans le
développement alors qu'ils auraient dû
être là pour nous aider
le cheval sert plus à la motorisation de
l'armée depuis les années 20 donc
aujourd'hui on utilise beaucoup plus
pour le loisir
donc on a eu une filière qui a connu
grâce à toutes les mesures prises par la
droite un essor extraordinaire puisque
on a créé plus de mille emplois par an
pendant 12 ou 13 ans aujourd'hui
puisqu'on est une filière à la fois sur
le à cheval sur le sport et le lot et
l'agriculture on est le premier
employeur du monde sportif
donc voilà pour reposer le débat moi je
me suis impliqué dans le dans la
représentation je crois que ça a été dit
tout à l'heure par paul hodé dans la
première table ronde c'est de notre
responsabilité nous les agriculteurs
français de nous impliquer aussi de
savoir nous impliquer à bruxelles
parce que comme en général la france
c'est bâtir l'europe mais c'est pas
l'utiliser quand on arrive à bruxelles
on se prend au camp nou si on reste en
france on prend tous dans la figure et
quand on arrive à bruxelles et qu'on
commence à prendre les dossiers ce qui
est mon cas au travers de ma présidence
du groupe cheval du copa cogeca alors
deux mots pour dire ce qu'est le copa
cogeca le
au passé la confédération de les
organisations professionnelles agricoles
le coc gecas la conf la confédération
générale des coopératives agricoles qui
ont été qui ont trouvé leurs racines
dans le traité de rome et qui ont été
créés à l'invitation des politiques aux
conventions de 58
le cop a été créé en 58 et le cocher 40
59 ayant fusionné les 262 donc
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 13 millions
d'agriculteurs
c'était l'époque 13 familles agricoles
dans les années 60
et c'est aujourd'hui 60 familles
agricoles pour les 28 états membres donc
il ya des groupes de production et il ya
notamment donc de toutes les productions
il ya des productions transversale
développement durable développement de
la ruralité et il ya déjà des groupes de
production pour les pour les ovins pour
les bovins enfin il y en a un pour le
cheval que j'ai la chance de près la
chance de présider ce qui m'a permis de
s'apercevoir que tout ce qu'on subissait
en france c'est la commission qui
travaillaient sur des projets je parle
notamment du transport des équipes et
pour ce qui me concerne mais du
bien-être animal des antilles des
aspects antimicrobiens tous que
déclenche la commission c'est des
discussions et des textes qui sont
créées par des ong
alors des ong il en faut il faut
défendre mais on a affaire des
extrémistes souvent et les
professionnels le monde de l'agriculture
n'est pas du tout et n'est pas du tout
écouter alors on n'est pas les seuls à
ne pas être présent ce qui est mon
premier travail dans le groupe du cheval
copa cogeca c'est de demander et avec
beaucoup de difficulté d'avoir des
rendez vous avec la commission
européenne pour leur expliquer que les
ong
eh bien c'était nos clients et que pour
que les clients soient satisfaits il
fallait aussi qu'il est producteur et si
les producteurs n'étaient pas
représentés dans les groupes de travail
on aurait du mal à bâtir pascal en avoir
des positions extrémistes qui sont les
positions des clients et pas celle qui
peut pas de ceux qui produisent donc
quand un résultat quand on arrive sur le
terrain du professionnel eh bien on
subit d'énormes qui nous sont imposées
auxquelles on n'a pas participé parce
qu'on n'était pas présent donc je pense
qu'il ya un vrai rôle alors ça demande
du temps mais il ya un vrai rôle à jouer
pour les agriculteurs français de ne pas
négliger cette représentation là le
copa-cogeca c'est des instances où on
discute et c'est surtout animée par les
familles
les familles nationale pour le pur pour
la france on a la chance d'avoir deux
familles nationale très impliqué et on
est très bien représentée par xavier
beulin mais bellaing pardon a besoin
d'appuis et il doit pouvoir compter sur
les forces vives et paul l'a bien dit ce
matin est le président de la fédération
porcine je pense que c'est de notre
responsabilité les aviculteurs de se
rendre plus disponible et d'être plus
présent pour ne pas avoir à subir ce qui
s'écrit dans notre dos et quand on
arrive en france tu l'a expliqué tout à
l'heure angélique on se retrouve avec
une sur réglementation française parce
qu'en france on aime bien compliqué ce
qui est simple voilà bah écoute merci
pascal pour ce pour ce train